I can go me lady okay me lady
dink-dink welcome back to the genitally
podcast no no no that's not me lady well
God we're in for it folks
it's a tick-tock you know it's not a
tick-tock
what squarespace wow it's a really great
website provider and if you want to
build a website you should do it was
Christmas because Keanu Reeves does the
end go to Squarespace comm slash Jenna
Julian save 10% off your first purchase
of a website or domain or check out a
free trial they are awesome 24/7
customer support can't say enough good
things really awesome way to build the
website also me Andy's incredibly soft
three times softer than cotton new
prints every month jen is wearing the
onesie they have ones these Brad socks
underwear and right now go to me undies
dot-com slash Jenna Julian get your 15%
off your first pair and save a hundred
percent free shipping and hundreds in
satisfaction guarantee on every purchase
also guys farmers dog feed your dogs the
food they want and need farmers dog he
provides human grade high quality and
people tested recipes for your dog's
personalized for your pets go to the
farmers dog calm slash annejulien to get
started with 50% off your first two week
trial of dog food thank you sponsors
well well we went out last night yeah I
am so violently hungover right now I'm
exhausted I cannot function Jenna I
don't drink white clothes because hard
alcohol makes me over also Jenna drinks
wine I'm hungover oh I feel so just like
not here where am i drooling
you're not here I woke up when I
immediately needed soup I'm the only
person I know that when I'm hungover all
I want to eat is soup it's like
clockwork what what's like o'clock you
drinking in the next day eating soup I
like soup it's really I'm not that way
with anything specific I wake up when
I'm hungover
I think I'm like everyone else when I
just like want bad food I don't have any
like hey what's she doing that's he it's
the little little hamster is running
around
oh it's Marvel yeah he's getting real
cheeky real cheeky marble yeah I mean
like like fried food you know any
anything that's really not good for you
I want what I crave when I'm hungover I
know you won't super I you just can't
grasp that I mean I can but I also like
I'd never want soup let alone when I'm
like craving the worst food I always
want soup anytime is a good time for
soup I disagree in the car yeah we do
you soup in the car in the in the in the
car when you're going off-roading yeah
we turbulence on a plane you making me
laugh there's a grape right now you tell
me don't poke me drinking wine we went
out to a bar we had fun we went on a
date date as friends cuz were just
friends and then like she was pouring
such like big glasses of wine for me and
um then we got home and I was like
Julian don't let me play any veteran
dungeon sign older scrolls what I do
logs on to a veteran dungeon right away
it's an Elder Scrolls thing 99.9% of you
wouldn't understand it it's a great game
I'm the only one that plays it I played
for night last night we we get we
decided well I decided and we decided
that we were gonna try to cut back on
weekend streams just so we can have the
weekend for ourselves and I think it's
been really good because I personally
shrink too much I mean I knew I was and
even if we're like gaming a little bit
here and there like it's it's been a
couple weeks of doing that I have no
weekends dreams or like last weekend
dreams at least and I feel much more
like a person yeah so last night Chris
was playing for 9:00 and I jumped on and
played with him how was fort night Julie
my god who's so good we got three wins
together just me and him I don't know
what it was maybe it was the vodka maybe
it was the playerbase on Saturday night
who knows but I am NOT a foreign I
player I've like never played I haven't
even have like ten hours in the game or
something if that yeah and it was just
really fun I say I don't know I don't
know what it was I was encouraging
though because of like I've wanted a
plate like for a night with Chris and
just some other friends and like Jeff
and get more into it because literally
everyone enjoys it and plays it so I
feel a little left out sometimes yeah
that everyone likes fortnight and I'm
like not into it
yeah is definitely like I don't know
it's it's like probably one of the only
mainstream things right now amongst my
peers that I feel like I am completely
left out of so it's cool to play it I
kind of just like took over that
conversation you were saying that you're
playing drunk elders Falls and then I
started talking about foreign aid but I
was I was playing drunk elders schools
like a 32 year old grown woman what is
going on he should go away why are you
guys bothering her they just walk up to
bunny like you hasn't been taking turns
walking up the bunny be like hey man
what are you doing and bunnies like
where's Carmen Oh God
but he's like I'm a whale she makes
whale I um yeah um we've been doing good
about podcasting early in the weekend
like Friday Thursday Friday this weekend
didn't happen for whatever reason here
we are on the South hungover Sunday oh
that's what we were talking about last
night yes I want to take judo okay I'm
gonna say this because I was trying to
not to say it last night I'm hungover
and tired but I want to take judo okay
when you're Mike's like this and you're
talking towards me just put the Mike in
a position where no because you're
looking at me this is how you podcast
guys podcast 101 if you have a co-host
point the mic as if the mic is aimed at
the cause I wanna take judo
well we were talking last night because
we were out drinking we were just having
a conversation we were talking about
jiu-jitsu and how I guess I was the I
was kind of the only person to expose
you to martial arts like that
yeah I was married kids where it was
like wanted karate like I did gymnastics
and dance Brandi yeah yeah I play
baseball and dance I do dance yeah using
them
show us your your videos of you dancing
there are those exists I want to say
100% exist I've danced in probably five
dance recitals yeah I want to see all of
them as a child and there is footage and
pictures of most most likely all of them
I've seen the one where you're wearing
like a jersey in a basketball I was just
one of them I was I was greased
lightning one year we played we did like
a like an Independence Day alien-themed
one I remember Marlon was an alien
Marlon was an alien in a dance recital
yeah yeah oh yeah you don't even know
dude we we were deep into this my mom's
best friend runs and ran a dance studio
as we grew up and my sister was a dancer
there all through her childhood and
taught there for many years
Chava M&R Dance Factory but um I we
would always be hanging around cuz we're
just the younger brothers and I'm
talking like we were young Marlon was
five six seven I was 8 9 10 11 12 we
were still just hanging around for 29 30
31 32 no so we were like we were just we
were just like disposable not disposable
you're like easy to like just toss in
the number oh you wear props where props
we need to get Marlon in here I might
have told the like these stories before
about him or I like him on it and Marlon
was just this cute little redhead curly
curly red hair like big curly red hair
and I was just this like a couple years
older than him thought I was cool and I
was like always doing this you know
Marlon by the way was eating a salad at
a Lil Wayne concert we're not gonna talk
about that I hope I go on his Instagram
and I look at it he's like in the stands
at a concert you
salad while lil wayne's on stage I I
don't get that boy sometimes you brother
he's one of a kind I thought I asked him
about I was like why eating a salad at a
concert he's like dude it was so good
okay why don't you eat the salad before
the concert it seems like a weird thing
to stand up hold a salad and eat it
while you're watching a concert
would you eat stupid a Lil Wayne concert
oh yeah I would say so you can't call
him weird okay I take everything back
okay the rats whining so do you want to
pick him up or something he's not rat
anyway so tell the money he did this
morning no no are you kidding we're not
talking about that no way he's nasty
work no no no no white no he was
standing there I was asleep and he's
licking my boob Julian gets very mad are
we live is this rolling no no no no it's
nothing it's live okay we're live I'm
gonna finish my story and the dog and
you if you could maybe let me do that
anyway there's no sorry we just used to
be in dance numbers and one time we were
all taking like a group pic and I mean
like a hundred people group pic cuz like
everyone in every dance number got on
stage and Marlon was the centerpiece cuz
he was in the opening number
and they photographers like one two
three and well and goes he wipes his
nose and like that's the photo it was
like this is the photo it exists it
exists I need to find it my mom probably
has it somewhere of him wiping his nose
in the photo my favorite thing that
Marlon does in pictures is some smile
and like a square I didn't know you
could smile into in a square but he can
and that's how he smiles in pictures
yeah like that show them that's how he
smiles like a small little square why I
don't know ask him why he smiles the way
he smiles the [ __ ] dog anyway we're
tangent in our faces off right now but
we were talking about jiu-jitsu and
Jenna was telling me that like she's
jealous that I have sort of a life sport
as an adult I can wake up and I can go
compete every day that I want to and
like better myself and we're
towards some sort of port I want a life
sport well and then I thought dude I was
like dude
judo is a lot of the a lot of the
technique and pace of jiu-jitsu with not
as much like mashing each other on the
ground mm-hmm choking no one's um
strangling me with my jacket
no one is breaking my arm sometimes
there it's like I don't know it looks
like the high level judo looks like I
don't know 30 seconds of like something
and then someone gets a point and then
you reset it's not like endless hours of
strangling each other it's a very
interesting sport that's why I hate
jiu-jitsu it's not the sport for me but
you've tossed me over you're over your
hips before like you know how to
distribute your weight like judo would
come easy to you I feel like knowing I
was we were seriously talking class well
no we were seriously talking about it
and I was I was like super excited to
hear that like you would be willing to
go to a class I would go with you I've
never done judo I have no idea as much
from a new Beemer I toss you in class
just friend yes you can toss me in class
what you're gonna do when you get tossed
by me boy you gonna cry or what yeah I'm
gonna lay on the phone man cried I feel
like the first time I get tossed that's
what I'm gonna do and then you're gonna
go man please leave the dojo and I'm
gonna go Casey and Jojo in the dojo and
then walk out I told you I'm hungover
I'm exhausted
what nothing I can't be non-functional
one time because that's what's going on
I know what's going on oh man they need
soup you just had soup
I need more you don't need more soup you
don't need more soup
it's minestrone okay it's really good
what's in minestrone soup vegetables and
pasta this one has like orzo pasta and
it's very tasty why do you look soup I
don't know I just just water and
vegetables yeah I like it a lot how do
you want to tell me what we did this on
Friday what we do on Friday
the show we did we filmed something oh
yeah with our trainers I can't like
Doc's their idea right we can't talk
about it yet I don't think probably not
but we um it was fun it was very cold
sore that's it that's the T so our
trainers have a cry of crowd therapy
chamber where it's like you go inside
the chamber it's for like recovery and
you know well it's like muscle recovery
what are the other benefits of it just
overall like soreness reduction yeah
sure like we use it for muscle recovery
we usually have it yeah so they have one
at the gym and it's basically like you
get inside the chamber it's so cold and
it can go from like anywhere from like
minus 160 fahrenheit to minus 220 230
Fairs I'm so cold
and they have they started the show I'm
not gonna explain it because it's like
their show
but part of it involves you going in the
chicken the crowded chamber and so we
did that and filmed it this weekend
which was really fun they put on the
coldest setting too for three minutes it
was terrible it was fun no it was awful
you're it's so cold your skin's like
burning yeah yeah I get like you get
really [ __ ] cold in there my legs
aren't sore though so that's a lot it
does do you actually believe it helps
you I think so
you don't think it's placebo you think
it might be no I think it definitely
does help
I just don't there's no way for me to
measure like how much it helps if you
don't do it versus when you do for it's
all dependent on your level of soreness
yeah but I definitely think it doesn't
it doesn't do nothing yeah I don't
definitely helps well I when are you
like for instance like when I used to
take ice baths like when I would only
really take a hide spasm and my legs
were totally shot like when I we had
worked legs or well I think it mainly
did him in college in high school
because those were the days then I would
just wasn't used to having my legs feel
like that and I would lay inside the ice
bath and it would be pure hell for like
two minutes and then it would be chill
cuz you're numb for like eight minutes
ten minutes and then you get out and I
remember the difference I would feel the
next day if I did ice bath reverses if I
didn't and I feel that same difference
with cryo hmm except it doesn't feel
like an ice bath if his
much better yeah it's a lot faster and
less wet unless having to go to the
[ __ ] liquor store and get six bags of
ice yes less of that but yeah it's it's
just like a cold tanning bed you just
walk in there you end up in it is it is
a cold tanning bed mm-hmm it's the
opposite of a tanning bed so I shouldn't
pitch that to me on Shark Tank cold hand
cold hand cold damn you have four gates
Hamblin very hot already I got a name
for it what Tundra ten hundred ten Wow
can attend like they do out in the
tundra amazing they have it is covered
yeah damn okay
Wow good sense don't you like not
functioning I like it though didn't they
tell me we're talking about how some NFL
player went in there barefoot and gave
himself frostbite on his feet Antonio
Brown I think really they didn't wear
shoes or for socks which you're supposed
to wear to protect your so you'll get
frostbite penny got respect
that's horrible maybe you should listen
to the rules I don't know I don't know
the whole story but maybe he should have
just worn what are you supposed to yeah
like socks in slippers and gloves and
usually like a hat and a mask too mm-hmm
and there's also a sign that says don't
don't be a pregnant lady and do this
yeah and don't go if you have
respiratory problems or heart problems
why are you staring at me just I'm
observing it's definitely more expensive
than ice baths mm-hm no it's not cheap
not cheap but it's cool anyway we filmed
inside one of those which was definitely
an interesting experience because we've
done it many times we never like filmed
inside one I've never done it on that
setting I've only done the baby setting
where it's like oh it's kind of chilly
go have a good time like like a light
breeze yeah
yeah then they [ __ ] blasted me this
time so cold anyway we'll keep you guys
posted on genna's and judo saga I
personally think I don't think am i
under
no that's what you always say I mean it
says I like the thing is it's like it's
very like any time you start a new sport
especially as an adult even like a new
activity or a hobby like it's scary as
[ __ ] dude it's like the most
intimidating thing to go into a new
place with other adults who have been
there and know each other you know it's
like the most anxiety inducing part of
your childhood a tree lived as an
adult's with other adults what do I wear
but you can do it what do I wear just
wear like I don't know like athletic
wear and then they give you a Guiteau
Tryon give me a giggy's yeah are you
kidding you know it's but you know
expected to go by Aggie before you know
if you're gonna join free Iggy's well
it's not free you probably get to keep
it with the membership chi chi use one
of your jiu-jitsu keys are the keys
different yes
oh how different the sleeves are shorter
and wider there's a wider opening in the
sleeves you notice okay cut your ghee to
be a judogi no you'd have to resew it
mmm okay and you know to the question
you're about to ask no you cannot cut my
geeky I want to do it I'm too scared I'm
not gonna do it well you come to my judo
competition it's coming up
you haven't even signed up for your
first class oh I just come okay welcome
to your competition
when is it well you guys come to come
watch me do judo I'll just get my ass
handed to me later dude I'm telling you
Nicolette or do I fight girls is what
co-ed judo the sport yeah I don't
participate in it I don't know but I
would imagine if you go to a gym and
you're a girl now your teammates are not
girls mm-hmm you would still train with
them right and then at a competition it
might be gender specific like you might
compete against the females how you feel
about that all these boys be tossing me
all day
you say you don't like the question I
don't care always always be tossing me
okay that's part of the sport that's
what happens sometimes a girl will show
up a few girls show up in jiu-jitsu and
I you just crush them with this joke
then I mash them
that's terrible no I treat them exactly
the same I treat them exactly the same
if you're lower about they get they get
work you know you get worked with you
have questions I'll help answer like
that kind of thing I'm sure there's a
lot but dude there's a lot of girls who
can [ __ ] bring it who we've trained
with so it's like you be just the same
you would go into a judo class and you'd
be hip toss and first of all I don't
know how its structured like I don't
someone walk in someone talks you know
someone who's watching absolutely has
done judo many people probably and could
help us in the comments but we could
also help ourselves by literally
googling what is the judo class like but
I would assume you warm up no no don't
do it hey Siri Siri doesn't wanna listen
to your last series no it's not hola
Siri Siri wait how do I get her to come
up Siri what's judo here's some
information I have to read with my
[ __ ] eyes she won't even read it to
me that says judo was originally created
in 1882 I thought oh okay 1882 yeah it's
so young by jigoro kano as a physical
mental and moral pedagogy with that word
I'm not done get to the important in
Japan it's generally categorized as a
modern martial art which later evolved
into a combat and Olympic sport it's
most prominent feature is its
competitive element where the objective
is to either throw or take down an
opponent to the ground immobilize or
otherwise subdue an appointment an
opponent or the pin
or force the opponent to submit with a
joint lock or choke I honestly I've
never even really thought about doing
judo but I love the idea of it because
it's it's like little pieces of jujitsu
and little pieces of wrestling and like
crackle Roman style like its own thing
and you were keys and I love that I
don't know I think you'd be [ __ ] good
and you can kick a little right you can
you can't kick for contact we can kick
to trip yeah yeah so you can have kick
people have you had it with me today no
oh you want to get some soup no what's
pedagogy what is that word am I done
judo pedagogy emphasizes randori
literally taking chaos but meaning free
practice Julian that's you taking chaos
are you excited yeah
are you actually gonna try it well
there's a picture of someone doing judo
and they're not wearing Aggie he's
wearing like a dress they're good judo
guys are very big they're like they're
baggy I think they're they're made to be
able to grab easier I think yeah I want
to kick someone in general so judo it's
a taking sports all kicks right it's not
all kicks there's no kicks
it's a tripping take down and like
pinning locking whatever well am I gonna
do if I just like can't do anything cuz
that broke my arm doing judo that's the
risk you take like that oh no
so they gonna give me about the first
day yeah ah is it gonna be a white belt
yeah do the same color progression in
jujitsu question I actually don't know I
think it is the same color progression
white blue purple brown black I think it
is I don't know though it should really
go white green blue purple gold like
elders Rose oh god no you didn't need
and
imagine though if you got into judo and
then we would do videos where it was
Jenna judo versus two issues you see
when you just throw me on my back yeah
all right I just tweeted should Jenna
try a judo and why wait you tweeted that
yeah for my side account it's gonna be
like yeah do it this may be a stupid
question but what makes judo different
from the other martial arts okay so if
we hadn't clarified that I'll clarify
that jujitsu involves yes it involves
takedowns but once one opponent has
taken another down and they're on the
floor that's sort of when jujitsu is
like beginning technically and so
there's grappling choking there's so
much choking there's choking but there's
it's grappling it's like wrestling on
the ground fighting for position you
know gripping each other's jeez it's so
painful and so uncomfortable all the
time you know do you don't want judo on
the other hand is you start on the feet
and the goal is to get the other person
on their back like to throw them over
your shoulder or to trip them to
basically take them down in a judo style
not in like a wrestling style where you
double leg them and once you get to that
position I believe you either get a
point or you try to parlay it into sort
of like an armbar really quickly or
something that that gives you the
advantage and then then it's over right
there's no fighting but in theory
jiu-jitsu would start where judo
finishes precisely like Stu Jitsu is the
ground thing yes exactly
yes I'm trying to stand you know I'm not
trying to just like lay down and have
some man on top of me choking me with my
own shirt some says do judo to prepare
for a basketball game well do you think
it would help no I don't think it would
translate at all in fact I think it
might make you worse at basketball
yes then you would instead of guarding
someone in a basketball game you would
just shoot out trick them I see I have a
problem with fouling and basketball as
it is I don't really understand what I
can and can't do so someone says no she
should play don't fight me on striking
vipers
you know what's funny is a lot it really
does feel like you're a more Jennifer
j'en of jiu-jitsu
it's like tailored to you more yes I'm
such like I think one of the reasons why
I like to Jitsu amongst many is like I
will be rolling with someone on the
ground for a long time I don't want that
hold on I just don't want that kind of
contact so I'm going I'm a Virgo oh
you're really annoying can you stop
talking when I'm talking thank you no no
stop okay
quiet I feel like this the pace of the
sport of jutsu is perfect for my energy
output because I am very fast-paced go
go go go go and then I'm like anyway I
think it'll be good for you I just need
like a quick burst and then it's over
that's what I mean I mean I feel like I
feel like it's kind of perfect for you
how about you how about you know I have
an idea no no no since your since you're
being hungover and annoying why don't
you read the sponsors that'd be funny no
no read the sponsors okay give it to me
why are you laughing cuz I'm gonna enjoy
this
don't read the email just click on the
attachments oh my god should I read the
email speaking of juda know everybody
loves Keanu Reeves he's a good dude oh
boy in John wick the matrix anyways did
you know over 200,000 companies use
Squarespace and make their websites
effective and customer friendly and both
Idris Elba and Keanu Reeves use
Squarespace for similar projects I like
both of them they know that Squarespace
is a customer friendly tool to build the
website of their dreams and speaking of
customer friendly what's better than
their award-winning 24/7 customer
support email or live chat or join join
a live webinar nothing's better than
that not literally nothing in life is
that better than a Squarespace well live
webinar
finding and maintaining a website can be
overwhelming they have fonts images
plugins hosting but Squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform that makes it easy
she's really selling me right now y'all
make sure you head over to Squarespace
calm for a free trial and when you're
ready to go launch go to Squarespace
calm slash Jenna Julian and save 10% off
amazing purchase of a website or Adomian
amazing thank you for that sponsor Reid
you're truly gifted thank you like I
don't know like you're seriously gifted
like the gift that you can get that
special someone from me on Dee's holiday
season I'm gonna in judo toss you bet
you won't I just don't know how yet we
could wear me undies onesies instead of
judo judo keys and practice me undies
judo get your loved one some me undies
they will thank you for it is the
softest underwear they've ever worn or
you've ever worn and they have awesome
prints they have couples prints they
have like matching prints they have
different styles of underwear they have
art prints basic prints all sorts of
different options for you to wear on you
bum and they last really long they feel
great I mean I can't say enough good
things about me undies they've recently
started pumping out these onesies which
personally I don't know about you
there's probably a few of you listening
that run hot I run hot onesies data for
onesies therefore never agreed with me
because I would always just get too
[ __ ] hot and just ditch the whole
thing and jump into the nearest body of
water but me undies came out with their
thin micro modal fabric onesies and so
now I can wear onesies just like all the
other cool people like China and I can
be stylish and it can be one convenient
piece of clothing for me and I'm not too
hot go to me on my outfit for me me
Andy's calm slash annejulien that's me
Andy's console Esther and Julien 15% I'm
for first pair and you'll love it you
just will and your dogs going to love
the food you get them from farmers dog
because you log on a farmer's dog and
you customize their food plan it's very
easy actually you answer a few questions
about your dog's food of choice their
eating habits they're just in general
everything about their diet currently
and they will formulate a plan of
high-quality food grade food
sorry human grade food that is tested on
people and developed for your pet
specifically using their board certified
veterinary experts all four of our
analyst top three all three of our dog
goes all four of our dog goes except for
marbles eat farmers dog marbles doesn't
eat he just eats air that's not true no
no he's just he just eats there it's
peachy time he does not eat air yeah
look at him rebel do you eat farmers dog
yeah he's farmers dog he loves it
marbles do you be there heats air also
sometimes he'll just go up air for hours
speaking of the dogs though buddy fell
in the pool bunny got really full and
her belly was nice and full of farmers
dog and she was running out back and yes
she found the pool go to farmers dog
calm so generally get 50% of your first
two weeks of your dog's custom-made meal
plan you will not be sorry check it out
yeah so I was outside this morning I was
upstairs actually I wasn't outside I was
at the the the table like right next to
the outside door to the back and I hear
like huge human splash and our neighbors
have a pool so we'll hear that sometimes
and I'm like oh I think that was them
but then I hear like the doggy paddling
or whatever and I look outside and she's
doing a little you know like kind of but
she's not panicking she's doing good
yeah and I run out there and I you know
I I was gonna dive in but I saw she was
totally fine like I wanted to kind of
let her figure it out but she slipped
into the pool from cutting the corner I
can find the clip somewhere it was like
try and round that corner roja the occur
mmit was way more [ __ ] he was going
directly towards the pool and decided to
cut the angle and slipped on the wood
but bunny just she does this she jumps
over the corner of the pool together
it's like a game yeah she loves it but
it's always making us like oh my one
time she like slipped and like caught
herself but apparently this time she
didn't catch resolve so she slipped on
the corner of the pool fell in and was
paddling paddling paddling and I helped
her but up but she eventually found her
way to like this shallow landing in the
deep end
where she usually walks into the pool
after like a walk shall walk and there's
like there's like this much water so she
can just stand in it and she she tried
the deep end wall and then the other
deep end wall and then was like okay I'm
gonna try the landing now and she got up
pretty high and I just kind of boosted
her butter and then she sprinted right
into the house she did yeah and soaked
up like her whole path and then went
into the gaming room like the room with
the most expensive equipment in our
house yeah and I was like outside
we hung out outside until she's right
off oh I'm proud of her for swimming out
of the pool it's kind of like a
necessary thing I feel well you know
what I'm confident that the times that
we've brought her in the pool with the
life vests under the water has helped
her yeah to the point of like when she
fell in today yeah cuz I mean she's not
outside if there's no one here like you
know we can't pay attention to her but
oh you know who you could judo Oh Ryan
Higa judo tossin he trained you know for
a lot of years oh he can teach me too he
give me about that would be a video I'd
watch Ryan teaches Jenna judo yeah but
that's part of it that's how you get
good are you saying no Ryan texted me
and you offered to do it you want me to
tell him no I'll tell them yeah one time
then I go Lauren raise your hand if you
want to see that video cuz I want to see
it but he would help teach you and then
maybe you would be like well first of
all here's the thing you have already
and you have zero training you have
already judo toss me a hip toss me
whatever you you taught me you know that
was Jiu Jitsu its Jiu Jitsu stealing
from judo is what it is it's not Jiu
Jitsu
it's like shall we report that crime you
would be good at it oh you would be
really good at it sorry you're saying
what if I get hurt whatever no you're
gonna be hurting people you're gonna be
just take up bowling again I we both
know that's not gonna fulfill your
competitive fully no I was Captain of my
bowling team at high school at
ball bowling sir yeah tell me one thing
about bowling that I don't know the oil
the lanes before we do that hmm
okay um this screen when there's like a
thing on it it's [ __ ] cool
damos does a 6-pack okay well did you
know that 9 out of 10 gamers are gamers
today I can't function I'm sorry I don't
know what to tell you
I'm gonna read more replies to that
tweak so I want to see why people think
you should do judo Mama's gonna give you
a kiss you just got so lucky you should
feel really lucky it could be your
hidden calling Chi compete
I just want to compete I want to do
competition and get a gold medal and
then laugh at everyone my competition
and say haha gamers get rekt what my mom
would probably come people just want it
for the content I mean they think that
you'd be good at it which I thought I
with my mom will come for sure your mom
would also be good at judo you know my
mom's had judo black belt according to
her lying to me about being a judo black
belt she said she got at the YMCA right
yeah I forget what I think in high
school my brother and I were starting to
like just to show interest in jiu-jitsu
and we were like oh my tragedy Jitsu and
then we were like roll around and you
know [ __ ] and yeah
oh I've done judo I was a black belt and
we're like mom we know what a judo black
belt is you're not that she's like no I
got one at the YMCA I didn't know you
could get a black belt in judo at the
YMCA well if you take it out of the bin
then it's yours then you got a black
dude I don't know what YMCA my mom's
talking about yeah where is the one's oh
you know it's probably like different 40
years ago yeah you right somewhere in
somewhere not here I've never been to
that YMCA have you been to all YMCA also
like
about a JCC there's a big mistake in
judo and jujitsu you don't you know just
like like some people I think I've heard
people say like oh I did judo when I was
a kid I got a black belt but I probably
don't know anything now no no that's not
no no that's not how it works at all if
you get anywhere close to a black belt
you've been training for upwards of 10
years it's not like oh yeah I was a
black belt when I was a kid I don't
remember much though no but don't the
kids have different that's like I think
that's more karate and Taekwondo and
stuff like that so cute I don't know
maybe I'm speaking wrong but again well
a little red belt that's how the cute
someone said I don't know what judo is
but I said yes okay judo toss you were
yes because she's a Virgo yes because
she'll kick so much ass
Omri kick ass yes so she could fight the
[ __ ] I'm ready to fight [ __ ]
anyway we talked about this for a long
time at the bar last night talking about
how it would be a great competitive
outlet for you and I I hold true to that
belief I think it would be really good
for you I think he's trying if I ever
did a jewel competition I'd let everyone
know you come watch me if you want
that's toxic me and greed after my judo
meet what do you call it a meet judo
meet I actually don't know I think a
fight No so we match match a judo chop
definitely is not a thing right no
there's no chopping meat maybe there is
I don't know I don't dude you know there
could be something called a judo chop
that I don't know about come to my judo
gathering why is he know it's not a judo
gathering judo as in a library
come to my judo gathering I'm competing
good luck everyone else Jenna being
hungover for an hour straight I'm very
tired can I have some of your coffee
yeah only if you come to a judo
gathering okay I was a shoulder I heard
that it popped from judo yeah how do you
like being a streamer with a webcam it's
fine yeah yeah but it's no judo you
negro what the hell kind of question is
that
I don't [ __ ] know how many boy I just
thought I'd ask
did you know that it's gamer time did
you know that 9 out of 10 gamers are
gamers give me that I need that for judo
you're not going to do don't have to do
later today oh no is this gonna turn
into that it's like basketball
I got judo later day I'm very tired I
need that energy for my my judo
gathering it sounds like a cult it's not
a gathering a judo meetup no judo jolly
time it is not called judo jolly time
can we do Ginga judo
cut stop screaming cut can we do Jenga
at judo Jason if you go to judo and you
come back telling me you played Jenga
the whole time yeah I very much you'd be
proud see oh you mean like human Jenga
you like to stand on top of each other
and one pulls out of the bottom and then
no no no I'm just gonna play Jenga and
judo with my friend Julian that's me
I'm not going who you said you'd come I
like I did at the beginning this podcast
but now I'm not going I'm gonna go train
yes sir you show up you put out Aggie
and you're just like so and when do we
start playing Jenga are we supposed to
bring our own Jenga or as well de Jing
er be provided that's actually a funny
idea playing Jenga in inappropriate
places yeah like on the train you just
bring the whole box of Jenga have you
played the big size Jenga yeah you used
to have it at your bar yeah yeah it was
terrible yeah oh it was very awful it
was soul that mix with alcohol is just
never a good idea no cuz you just be
like sitting there minding your business
and some drunk people are playing giant
Jenga and all of a sudden it collapses
it's like it's sad it's terrifying it's
a very loud yeah it's like a big
crumbling creaking but it's like behind
you and now you're scared shitless
where's the worst place you think you
play Jenga I'm already thinking of
terrible places I know what inconvenient
place is not like morally awful please
no no here you start a game of Jenga
right before everyone straps in for that
fair ride when you go up against the
wall and it spins oh hell yeah this
would just be flying all over the place
smacking people and head hell no no
Tower of Terror when they do that 50/50
story job hmm
so the Jenga is just floating above
everyone and then crashed down on OK on
the bowling lane no that would be great
because then you would not call Jenga
pins over right during the service of
someone's bar mitzvah you just pull out
your own Jenga set I can't think of a
more like intrusive hobby to be taking
engineer I'm late to do Jenga
maybe that's all really all this is I
don't actually want to do judo but I
needed to get here which is my passion
is Jenga you suck its anger are there
any like professional Jenga players I
don't know look it up is there Pro Jenga
Siri your phone's literally off oh my
god
Siri are there any professional Jenga
players God Siri I'm so sorry
why is your Siri like from 2005 I found
I juggle she just brought up I juggled
idea is that a porn oh my no it's no t
monetize Cut Pro will cut the porn out
fish no Ginga doesn't exist those
congressional jingle rules yaha Jenga
premium hardwood game rules Major League
Jacob I'm gonna get drafting there's not
major league I'm gonna get drafted it
MLJ official league rule set mlj way are
you serious are you making this up I'm
not
says major-league Jenga oh my god okay
um do you guys have a tab as to how I
can get drafted you know I don't think
this is real
doesn't look like a good website ie it
wasn't Don's first phase sorry no you're
right
this is just like a it's a group of
friends I feel like it's a club in their
high school that they started a website
for I'm I'm not joking this says the
vice vice president was one of the key
originators and believers of the MLJ
dream as they always say when the Vice
walks in he knows what's happening oh my
god I don't think this is not real that
is not real when the Vice walks in he
knows what's happened in there's someone
named turtleneck that plays in this
league this is a whole world where
discovered turtlenecks named spawns from
his extreme surfaced in creating a
turtleneck effect yeah this is
definitely legit mm-hmm
sorry about this entire podcast yeah I
concur anyways I don't think I can get
drafted into that Django League but I'm
gonna make my own I decided that I'm too
tired for judo
I can't me you haven't even tried out
one single time don't yawn after you not
even try to I didn't yawn I took a
breath
don't take deep sigh breaths after you
haven't even tried it I went in my mind
and I decided that it was you could
train with Ronda no she hasn't trained
anymore she's a judo bronze medalist in
the Olympics she knows judo forever you
act like I can just like call her like
hey there's this train I'm sure she
would train you on type of judo where
you lay down in shavasana the hole that
is not judo or yoga that's just laying
on your back I like that I want to
competitively lay on my back that sounds
wrong I'm sorry
okay back to Ginga wait who would you
use to ask savasana like our trainer
would you ask you said that like a lot
someone when are we doing shavasana yeah
probably does a trainer yeah probably
it's a funny joke
listen no no it wasn't yeah he'll be
rocking the weights for us to squat and
I go Kai shavasana instead kai kai show
vaasana' instead like like like
shavasana really is just laying down
it's like an actual pose that you're
supposed to be like it's more than
breathing and being mindful me a Western
yogi that doesn't know how to show off
their brain it is just laying down
you're a westerner but you ain't no yogi
Caixa vaasana' you a yogi ponder about
this fact you're not supposed to ponder
in shavasana you're supposed to turn
your brain off and breathe and close
your practice or open your practice okay
close me eyes hold my breath no what no
don't hold your breath
absolutely the opposite that's out okay
okay
so by shavasana meaning it's an author
and leave the room Gatorade
oh I want to get you to read okay YUM
okay oh are you done again I said I'm
sorry okay I'm sorry for being a mess no
that's okay I'm sorry I think it's
charming she's I joined judo or Jenko
let me know it's legendre no she should
do judo or Ginga in the comments below I
personally want to see you do judo all
jokes aside cuz this podcast has been
all jokes I genuinely think that judo is
something you it excel at you would find
fun and would most importantly scratch
that competitive physical itch that you
that you have right now yeah I just want
to do something competitive as an adult
Jenga is looking pretty nice though well
then to all our competitive Jenga
players and our judo cos out there thank
you for listening and everyone else as
well and Thank You Siri for being here
no no you do not get to shout out that
bunk ass fake Siri off-brand [ __ ] that
you were trying to talk to that is not
serious I don't know what that was but
it ain't serious you my deepest
condolences if you listen to this whole
podcast I'm sorry I apologize to your
time and the rest of your schedule but I
hope you guys have a wonderful week
we'll be live on Twitch all week now
with Jenna cam on stream if you want to
see her beat him she's on more hydrated
and less tired
next time we go live than I am right now
Beach the end bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]